Mom was losing her short-term memory,
butwas better recalling
her younger years.
I'd ask, and she would tell me stories.
Ilistened, and I was her audience.
I got ideas. I wrote them down,
and I sketched them out.
I showedher what to do by
acting out the scenarios myself.
We would then stage them.
So she posed,
and I learned more
about photography.
Mom loved the process, the acting.
She feltworthy again, she
felt wanted and needed.
With any Alzheimer's, dementia, there's
a certain amount of frustration
and sadnessfor everyone involved.
But to balance off all
the difficulties, we played.
That was Mom'shappy place.
And I needed her to be there, too.